you you write about alien intelligences
yes I mean just these worlds yes well
computation problem with these worlds is
that we can't talk to them yes and and
you know the thing is what I've kind of
spent a lot of time doing is just
studying computational systems seeing
what they do what I now call ruliology
kind of just the study of rules yeah and
what they do you know you can kind of
easily jump somewhere else in the
rouliad and start seeing what do these
rules do yeah and what you says they
they just they do what they do and
there's no human connection so to speak
because do you think you know some
people are able to uh
uh communicate with animals do you think
you can become a Whisperer of these
quietition trying that's what I've spent
some part of my life have you have you
heard and are you at the risk of losing
your mind sort of my favorite science
discovery
is this fact that these very simple
programs can produce very complicated
Behavior yeah and that and that fact is
kind of in a sense a whispering of
something out in the computational
universe that we didn't really know was
there before I mean it's you know I it's
like you know back in the 1980s I was
doing a bunch of work with some very
very good mathematicians and they were
like trying to pick away you know can we
figure out what's going on in these
computational systems and they they
basically said look the math we have
just doesn't get anywhere with this
we're stuck there's nothing to say we
have nothing to say and you know in a
sense perhaps my main achievement at
that time was to realize that the very
fact that the the good mathematicians
had nothing to say was itself a very
interesting thing that was kind of a
sort of in some sense a whispering of a
different part of the rouliad that one
hadn't you know one wasn't was not
accessible from what we knew in MA and
so on
does it make you sad that you're
exploring some these gigantic ideas and
it feels like we're on the verge of
breaking through to some very
interesting discoveries
and yet you're just a finite being
that's going to die way too soon and
that scan of your brain or your full
body kind of shows that you're yeah it's
just a bunch of meat it's just a bunch
of meat
um yeah does that make you make you a
little sad kind of a shy I mean I kind
of like to see how all this stuff works
out but I think the thing to realize you
know it's an interesting sort of thought
experiment you know you you say okay you
know let's assume we can get cryonics to
work and one day it will that will be
one of these things that's kind of like
chat GPT one day somebody will figure
out you know how to get water from zero
degrees Centigrade down to you know
minus 44 or something without it
expanding and you know cryonics will be
solved and you'll be able to like just
uh you know put a pause in so to speak
and you know uh kind of reappear 100
years later or something and the thing
though that I've kind of increasingly
realized is that in a sense this this
whole question of kind of the the
um sort of one is embedded in a certain
moment in in time and you know kind of
the things we care about now the things
I care about now for example had I lived
you know 500 years ago many of the
things I care about now it's like that's
totally bizarre I mean nobody would care
about that it's not even the thing one
thinks about
in the future the things that most
people will think about you know one
will be a strange relic of thinking
about you know the kind of you know it
might be What Might Have Been a
theologian thinking about you know how
many angels fit on the head of a pin or
something and that might have been the
you know the big intellectual thing so I
think it's a it's a um uh but yeah it's
a it's a you know it's one of these
things where particularly you know I've
had the I don't know good or bad fortune
I'm not sure I think it's it's a mixed
thing that I've you know I've invented a
bunch of things which I kind of can I
think see well enough what's going to
happen that you know in 50 years 100
years whatever assuming the world
doesn't exterminate itself so to speak
you know these are things that will be
sort of centrally important to what's
going on and it's kind of both it's both
a good thing and a bad thing in terms of
the passage of one's life I mean it's
kind of like if everything I'd figured
out was like okay I figured it out when
I was 25 years old and everybody says
it's great and we're done and it's like
okay but I'm gonna live another how many
years and that's kind of it's all
downhill from there in a sense it's it's
better in some sense to to be able to
you know there's there's it sort of
keeps things interesting that you know
why I can see you know a lot of these
things I mean it's kind of I I didn't
expect you know chat GPT I didn't expect
the kind of uh the sort of opening up of
this idea of computation and
computational language that's been made
possible by this I didn't expect that
this is this is ahead of schedule so to
speak
um you know even though the sort of the
the big kind of flowering of that stuff
I'd sort of been assuming was another 50
years away so if it turns out it's a lot
less time that's pretty cool because you
know I'll hopefully get to see it so to
speak rather than
well I I think I speak for a very very
large number of people in saying that I
hope you stick around for a long time to
come you've had so many interesting
ideas you've created so many interesting
systems over the years and I can't see
now that GPT and language models broke
open the world even more I can't wait to
see uh you at the Forefront of this
development what you what you do
and uh yeah I've been a fan of yours
like I've told you many many times since
the very beginning I'm deeply grateful
that you wrote a new kind of science
that you explored this mystery of
cellular automata and inspired this one
little kid in me uh to to pursue
artificial intelligence and all this
beautiful world so soon thank you so
much it's a huge honor to talk to you to
to just be able to pick your mind and to
explore all these ideas with you and
please keep going and I can't wait to
see what you come up with next and thank
you for talking today thanks we went
past midnight we only did uh four and a
half hours I mean we could probably go
for four more but we'll save that until
next time to uh this is round number
four well I'm sure talk many more times
thank you so much my pleasure